this is
today in İstanbul
self-critical
ostep Vestel forward to ensuring the safe and
exporter you cream of football Robert liquid
boxy
again volt Arkın ve Global crazies to
date Last job
to is suffering and
Gold
Country you pipo
system
boltur
verisun
next week and of free We both to  End
Of
good Will Smith barbecue party Solid From this
up Time optimistic,
these include the
establishment of a joint coordination center in Istanbul,
joint team checks on departures and arrivals from ports, as
well as
ensuring the safety of the navigation routes of the ships here for agriculture and other good friends
.  We have seen many techniques and tactics
here with arrogance,
and we see that
the parties are willing to solve this problem, and
we will hopefully
try to reach a conclusion by
executing the
united meter issues in a way.
They agreed to hold a meeting in Turkey. Consensus was reached that it was agreed. First
came,
we will review all the details once again and this
will be signed in those years.
and our
hope is that our wish will be this grain as soon as possible and then
it will be resolved we are keeping our
feet in it i am assessing
that it will come to a full conclusion next week